welcome to the hits virtual north
america regional session
we hope you're enjoying the conference
my name is shireen darwish i'm the north
america market development manager at
thermo fisher scientific
and we're delighted to bring you this
next session featuring three expert
presentations focused on how dna is used
by law enforcement and crime labs
to solve crime please be sure to submit
your questions for each of the three
presenters in the q a box on your left
and as a reminder this session offers
free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits for a complete biography on
all three of our speakers please visit
the tab at the top of your screen
it's my pleasure to introduce to you our
first presenter
stephanie regan crime scene and
laboratory unit supervisor at the kauai
police department
thank you for attending hits and also
thank you for attending this
presentation block my name is stephanie
regan and i'm the supervisor of the
crime scene and laboratory unit at the
kauai police department
today i'll be speaking on our use of
rapid dna
for a helicopter case for disaster
victim identification
so just a quick disclaimer this is an
actual
kauai police department case and this is
not for
any legal or prosecution purposes out of
confidentiality for the victims and
those affected by the crash
do not capture or share any part of this
presentation
except with the express written consent
of the kauai police department
just a quick content warning the
following presentation does provide an
account of a disaster victim
identification from an
actual helicopter crash so images and
content
may be disturbing to some viewers
therefore viewer discretion is advised
i want to take a brief moment just to
pause and acknowledge those that were
lost during this crash
and the families that lost loved ones
during this incident
on december 26 2019 we had a crash on
the northwest coast of kauai
kauai is the westmost island of the
hawaiian chain
and here's a general depiction of the um
start of that cliffside
so the helicopter went down generally in
this
region and to give you a little
understanding of how
tough this terrain is
this is how i ended up having to get
into the scene to actually do
any uh victim identification recovery
and uh helicopter part recovery and
so basically it's just steep cliff all
the way throughout this
and the helicopter impacted uh we'll
show a quick video here next
but the helicopter actually impacted one
of the cliff sides
where it fell approximately 100 feet uh
to the bottom
and a caught on fire there at the bottom
which further complicated all of the
recovery of the remains
as well as the reconstruction of the
actual crash
so you'll see in the video it's actually
myself and one of our detectives
they're at the bottom of the cliffside
actually in the cockpit area
and we're doing some parts
identifications and photographies for
the engineer
but you can actually see how steep that
cliff is behind me
and then the arc at the top of the dirt
is actually where you will have
um you'll actually see where the actual
aircraft impacted
to give you a quick overview of the
actual timeline
of the victim identification process the
helicopter crash actually happened on
the 26th
um it was not found on the 26th
and it was actually a missing aircraft
during that time
so the helicopter crashed on the 26th
and was actually located on the 27th
where remains recovery was able to be
taking place so based on how difficult
the terrain was the recovery actually
expanded over most of the weekend
our medical examiner is actually off
island so they have to fly over to do
autopsies
um so it actually took a few days for
them to also get here and started the
autopsies on tuesday the 31st
um most of the autopsy took place on the
31st and the second
where during that time 28 different body
parts were able to be identified
at that time 16 were determined by the
medical examiner to possibly be viable
for dna analysis they did take pictures
of the 12 additional samples
but at that time they didn't sample them
i began my
testing on the second and kind of pretty
much all the way through till the 8th
on the third i actually sent those
pictures out to my support team at
thermo fisher scientific
of the 12 remaining samples that were
deemed originally as probably not being
able to be identified
and from case experience they actually
told me that it would be useful
or it would be potentially useful to go
ahead and actually test
those samples so monday i ended up
sending a colleague back to take
additional samples
of those 12 samples that weren't
originally
taken and we ended up testing those as
well
one of the biggest things in this case
was during the autopsy
portion there was actually only able or
they were only able to identify
six different distinct uh bodies from
doing body part elimination
so from the offset we are a little bit
concerned that we wouldn't be able to id
all seven victims and also weren't in
that
regards gonna be able to get the death
certificates and anyone that's done
disaster victim identification knows if
you can't get death certificates legally
it becomes very challenging
and it puts a huge burden on the
families on trying to move forward with
all of the different processes needed
after end of life care um
so you know from the offset we weren't
sure we were going to be able to do that
and within three days from the time that
we
finished the autopsies and had the
samples to test
till sunday and again running pretty
much even half capacity on the weekends
um we were able to id all seven victims
via dna uh by the fifth on sunday so
that was huge
knowing that we would be able to cut all
seven death certificates
to allow that legal process to move
forward again on monday
those 12 additional samples were taken
and on
um on monday and then on the 7th
i was able to process all 12 of those
samples successfully iding every single
one
back to the person that they came from
and then
on the 8th approximately 2 weeks from
the crash
we were able to authorize release of
every single one
of the 28 samples um
the system at the bottom the applied
biosystems rapid hit id
system from thermo fisher scientific is
what we ended up using
to id all of the different uh remains
so a quick overview of the cost savings
that we had in this case
as well as the time savings so if
based on the in-house rapid dna
processing we only spent about 3
200 to process all of the different
samples that we needed both family
samples
and the remain samples and we were able
to release those as you saw on the last
slide
on january 8th for us we didn't think
that our state lab would be able to
take the identification process for this
case so we would have had to go toward
to our outsourcing private lab
and our private lab is actually on the
mainland so um
that adds a little bit of time to our
actual turnaround time for
identification
so it takes a few days for us usually to
get the authorization and paperwork and
fiscal stuff done and then as well
as shipping time to get those samples
out
so as you as you know most of the
companies have different outsourcing
ones
so for us the fastest we would have been
able to do as a five-day expedite on the
dna processing
and about 10 times the cost so it had
been 32 000 in
in comparison to 3200
so about 10 times the cost and we still
wouldn't have been able to release the
bodies
for another few weeks and then you know
you have different
outsourcing expedites um so it would
have ranged
in price a little bit but still almost
10 times as much
cost and you would we've been looking
for at least another month
based on the different expedited charges
until we would be able to release those
samples
um our standard outsourcing time still
would have been five times the cost of
our disposable cost
and it would have been about two months
later that we would have been
releasing those bodies back to their
families
so just a quick um highlight summary uh
all
28 body parts were able to be identified
and authorized
for release within two weeks of the
crash and actually one week
from the autopsies being completed and
testing being able to be started
all seven victims were identified via
rapid dna within three days of the
autopsy completion and those were
weekend days as well for this one case
alone
we were able to use rapid hit id to save
between 20 000 to 30 000 and up to two
months of time
and again that's being able to release
remains back to their loved ones and
let them move on in the process of
having closure
okay so lessons that we learned
throughout this process
first and foremost was uh that with the
burnt remains
was to test everything so again
initially we didn't take uh samples from
all of the more burnt remains and this
is a good example
of some of the remains that we had so as
you can see
there is a lot of fire damage to the
smaller remains
and we were able to end up going back
and
identify every single one that was
determined to be human
so at the end of the day if you can
determine that it's actually a human
tissue
go ahead and actually test it
this is the sample that actually was the
worst profile that i was able to do um
but again this was this is very fire
damaged um
and only took a very small sample from
this tissue and were able to get enough
of the profile
to be able to identify back again if
you're doing a
large database search or anything like
that uh probably wouldn't be able to
make the id
uh but with the nf7 it was able to give
a
enough um profile to be be able to
attribute that back to the person that
it came from
uh here is a muscle tissue and um
again very badly burnt um and for a
little bit of a
perspective here this bottom of the tube
here is
only about eight millimeters wide so you
only need a very small
sample to be able to actually run it run
the
rapid dna system on it
this sample is actually pretty good you
can
see that the small sample that we were
able to take for actual testing is
pretty viable tissue
um but in this circumstance you had most
of the end of this bone and also the
rest that wasn't sampled
that is pretty badly burnt
and again this is only a really small
sample and it's only about as thin
as the scalpel itself
here's an example of brain tissue that
was found
and again it's covered in a lot of dirt
and as well as
burnt sample and if you
see here in that top left portion or
top center portion of the sample we were
able to
take the swab and get enough clean
sample
all you need is a very small amount on
the tip of the swab
to be able to load into the rapid hit
cartridge
and run and i think this one got
actually a full
profile another lesson learned
uh was that with burnt remains comes ash
and with ash comes sediment
so um this is actually the first burnt
muscle
that i ran and you can actually see that
if you look in the well you can see the
ash kind of building up in the well
as well as running down into the
capillaries of
the rapid hit cartridge so you can see
the ash going down into both the
um that first well as well as both of
the capillaries right there in
uh connecting the cartridge um
this one actually caused a ladder error
and
but we were able to recover that in the
data analysis phase
uh we did re-run that sample just to be
sure but it was
actually a recoverable error that
occurred to resolve that moving forward
we did a very simple wash so nothing
fancy but we just took an eppendorf tube
placed our sample inside of it and then
did a quick wash
uh with sterile water turned it up and
down a few times
and uh that was it uh so we usually did
a double wash
this helped in both getting rid of that
sediment and also kind of doing a
pre-hydration of the sample
and we didn't see any errors throughout
the remainder of the
testing after that point
the last lesson learned is that burnt
remains
uh is gonna be degradation um and the
samples and the results and the data
that you're gonna get is gonna reflect
that degradation
um so with that a lot of people are
thinking on the rapid
dna side that it's a hands-off system
but the hands-off system portion of
rapid dna
is really designed for blood and vehicle
samples
so with that uh with the degradation
samples you will have to have somebody
that can do the data analysis and data
review
so you'll need somebody to be able to go
in the trace files and actually confirm
whether or not certain calls are correct
and clean up that data
so then you can go back and do your
match comparisons
or the kinship analysis further the
rapid hit id
software is really again designed
for the hands-off blood and bugle type
comparisons
so you might have to do some
troubleshooting uh with these degraded
samples
as far as being able to actually
generate those reports if you're relying
on the rapid hit
uh software so i i know a lot of labs
they do use
uh both the built-in software or they
might have secondary software that
you're doing uh the analytics part of it
in so if you're doing that secondary
analytics no issue there
but if you're trying to use the rapid
hit software you may have to do some
troubleshooting
but in this i was in direct contact with
the thermo fisher scientific support
team
and they were excellent in giving me
timely turnaround
and working through some of those issues
on the back end so that we could
actually generate
all of the match reports needed as well
as
the kinship analysis that was done um so
just some things to know
again we were able to work through all
those errors and luckily enough we do
have uh the biological backgrounds
in-house for us
to be able to do all of the data
analysis
with that i'll take a few minutes for
questions my contact information is here
on the slide
so if you have any questions uh post
symposium then
i'm happy to answer any emails or calls
that you may have thank you
well thank you shireen and thank you
very much for this opportunity to
present to you
virtually today i really appreciate it
and i'm thankful for the the platform to
be able to do this
from and today what i want to talk to
you about is
maintaining productive momentum in a
rapidly evolving dna lab
this is a reality for my laboratory
right now
as we've spent the last several months
becoming much more productive in the
work that we
do and it's one thing to be able to
become more productive
and change what needs to be changed to
get there but it's a
it's quite another issue to maintain
that productivity because there's
various factors involved
in how you move from where you were to
where you want to be
and keeping that going in the right
direction so if you'll indulge me for
just a few minutes
today i would love to just share with
you my thoughts
and experiences from our team's
perspective as to how
we are doing and and getting towards
where we eventually want to be
now this is something that nobody wants
to hear from any biologist that's the
facts
of life but i'm going to share them with
you anyway especially when it comes to
the facts regarding having to change
because some of it is hard change is
really
hard when it comes down to implementing
it
change is also fairly uncomfortable for
the
most part because we get pretty
comfortable
in our routines in our processes we get
comfortable
with the people that we work with and so
to change all of that
is quite uncomfortable and it's also
exhausting
change at first can be exciting but it's
almost like an adrenaline kick where you
start to do something and everybody gets
excited and can see
the big picture but after you've been
gone for a little while and that
initial excitement has worn off you
suddenly get exhausted and it's really
important in the middle of all of this
that you can still maintain momentum
change is also risky so going into any
kind of
full-scale change especially within a
laboratory that's doing
very important work that affects
people's lives
on a daily basis you have to weigh up
the risk
is changing this process or is changing
this instrument or is changing
this chemistry or is even changing to a
different workflow and different
personnel being involved
is it worth the risk and so that is
something
that is effective implementing change
so that you can continue to evolve
as a dna laboratory
and in forensics of course change is
slow
so back to that first point of
implementing because of excitement and
knowing that you want to see the
end product of the big picture in
forensics we all know that that now
takes a long time for some good reasons
of course we deal in a legal system that
has to be very careful
and rightly so that everything is tested
and validated and tested again and
changed and tweaked and
trained and and everything involved with
it takes time and so just by expressing
the fact that you want to move to a
better
way of doing things a more productive
way of doing things doesn't
necessarily mean that that idea is going
to be
implemented anytime soon so
in the maintenance of the momentum
especially within the
arena of forensics it can be quite
frustrating to implement
change because we know ahead of time
that it's going to take
a long time to get to where you want to
be
but on the upside change is certainly
necessary we're
a scientific field and we need to move
with the science we need to move with
the technology we need to
be able to offer to our community our
customers the people we
serve on a daily basis we need to offer
them the
latest and the greatest as is
appropriate so
we can't stay back in the ways that we
were doing things 5
10 15 sometimes 20 years ago
changes absolutely necessary so that we
can give the best
possible work product to those people
that we serve every day and change can
and should be productive and if it's not
then you start again or
you scrap it but that's part of the risk
that you've assessed
before you've gone into this endeavor
so for us what has changed and in
reality
we have become fully staffed over the
last couple of years which is something
that i know many labs
struggle with but for ourselves one of
the big changes that needed to be made
was more personnel
and so i'm thrilled as our management
team that we have
the people in place at the appropriate
level to do the job that we want to
do we've changed our training program
which
came with its pros and its cons but
instead of
doing things a certain way and waiting
for everybody to train
in in the entire in the entire process
we've gone to a task-based training
program where we can introduce our
analysts
especially the new folks who've just
come on board into the
actual workflow at a necessary stage so
that we can
one make them feel productive but two
and more importantly
um improve our workflow with their input
into these key areas
because of that and because of our
instrumentation
and our upgrades through technologies
and validations we've increased our
throughput capacity in the last 10 to 15
months
by 500 that doesn't mean that that's
what we're seeing yet
but we've given ourselves that room to
grow and that is
really encouraging for us sometimes a
little scary but certainly encouraging
to know that that's what
that's what we can fill that's kind of
the shoes we can step into
and as we continue to get better and
maintain this improvement and private
productivity
we know what it is that we can reach as
a ceiling because of our
increased capacity
in the last 10 months for example and
i'll show you this figure again in a few
moments we've increased our productivity
100
so see the direction and the momentum
that we've got going on
in our lab right now
and i'm thrilled that this year just a
couple of months ago in april for the
first time ever
since i arrived in this lab which was a
little more than three years ago now
we've completed more cases than we've
had
requests to perform work and analysis on
so i'm happy to see that and again it's
just another great indication that is
shared with our team
our management and our wider public
community
to show them that we're doing what
they're asking us to do and we're doing
it well
we also set realistic but ambitious
goals
that's changed because the old habit
really and i'm sure this is the same in
multiple locations
is to just keep plodding along in that
comfort zone
but in order to get better and to
improve and to increase that
momentum and productivity you have to
set some ambitious but realistic goals
and we've done that
together and i'd encourage you to do
exactly the same don't just be happy
even if you're a
highly productive lab that's getting the
work done in a timely manner still go
ahead and set
ambitious goals that are realistic and
continue to improve
because losing that momentum eventually
through exhaustion
can lead to some kind of backtracking
and so for us
we set those goals that were realistic
but they were really ambitious
and then what we did in order to hold
our feet to the fire
and was to publicize our expectations
so on local news channels through public
meetings certainly to the
command staff in our agency all of our
expectations and goals were publicized
and that makes me very nervous but
that's okay that's why i have the role i
have and that's why
my manager has their role too so that we
can
continue to push that expectation
downwards while
also being accountable upwards for what
it is that we
really want to do so here's what i was
talking about
a little while ago just a really quick
comparison of the 10 months
in blue prior to implementing all of our
changes in the lab
so the y-axis is just the percentage of
cases cumulatively that were put out
over that 10-month period
and so of course month 10 is 100 of what
we did
for the prior 10 months and then
comparing that to the 10 months
directly after implementing the changes
that we've done so far
and we see an almost 200 percent
realization of what we've seen in the
previous 10 months there so
with the curve still trending upwards
for us we're thrilled to see that we're
going in the right direction and for me
to know that this just involves um 20
of the new personnel being productive in
these figures
gives me great hope that that will
continue to rise and rise
and rise over the next year to two years
and will certainly be in a wonderful
position in the very near future
one of the things that really is
exciting for me is to be able to change
the instrumentation and the technology
is just a small
number of the new instruments that we
were able to bring on board
during this period of change and from
automated extraction
robots to upgraded ce instruments and
more consistent
and pcr instrumentation and even a rapid
dna
the rapid hit id and dna
system for our codis confirmation
samples these all together along with
the new protocols the new validations
the new chemistries
and certainly by no means least the new
staffing
has caused us to have these increases in
productivity and
maintain that momentum
so why is the change been effective
well what we did first of all was
identified our problems now problems
were really with productivity
we were asked to do a job and we weren't
getting it done in a timely manner we
were getting it done eventually but
we needed to get it done better more
efficiently and more effectively
we set ourselves some very clear goals
timelines dates numbers that we have to
achieve
and i would encourage you to do the same
don't be fluffy and fuzzy about the
things that
you have to achieve be very clear and
succinct in identifying what it is
that you need and want to do
we garnished strong support and that
support was both from our leadership
within
my agency and the community at large
again that came with the publicizing of
our expectations
and our challenges too but getting the
leadership and the community on board
with us
and wanting to have us succeed was
really important in obtaining
their support we
by no means in a small way partnership
with thermo fisher scientific
for our validation studies our upgraded
chemistries
our um new instrumentation and and i
couldn't be more grateful to
them for their health their
encouragement and their constant
and consistent crucial support over this
time period and we have big plans for
the future too where we're continuing
to upgrade our workflows and our systems
too so that was certainly a huge part of
our success
we had in-house commitment from those in
the same level
as myself and the bench level analysts
too
and it's really important that as a
management team we're able to maintain
enthusiasm and the resolution to succeed
from the analysts on the ground who are
actually implementing this change
and performing the work that needs to be
done
so finally what does that mean well for
us to maintain this
momentum we have to say what are our
minimum
expectations what's the projections that
we have
in order to keep this going in the right
direction
and here it is and then might just look
like numbers to you but for me these are
realities and so in the remainder of
this current calendar year that we're in
we've predicted that at minimum we're
able to complete
152 of everything that we know
because of the historical data we've
gathered
of all that we're going to be asked to
do in this
remain remaining portion of 2020.
so that's great and that is something
that we have as a very clear
goal to achieve but then we needed to
look ahead to
2021 and as we carry over the current
backlog to
next year as well a portion of it at
least
and expect to get the regular number of
cases
in-house for us to complete we predict
at minimum
we will cover everything that we're
asked to do including that backlog
and buy a little bit more and again i
say that's a minimum i do expect more
but i want to be realistic about what we
expect
and if you're not realistic then you're
not going to maintain
that momentum in progressing through the
work that you need to do
so the result of that is very clear in
my mind
and the result is that we're going to
completely eliminate our backlog
and we're going to complete all of our
in-house cases within
our state mandated time frame by the end
of this
year which thrills me and not only me
but also my leadership team too
in uh in thinking about next year it
also means that we're going to have a
surplus capacity available to us in 2021
which
means that we can do even more maybe
decrease the turnaround times
more we can accept more case types of um
cases that we don't currently accept in
our laboratory and
look ahead to other validation studies
research and special projects that we
have in our minds and in our hearts to
get on with so that's what we can look
forward to because
of this and with that i just want to
thank you
and hand it back to shireen for any
questions that might have
come in during this presentation thank
you very much
and i'm going to give is around talking
about new
tools that we have in our portfolio to
improve efficiency and save time
namely we're going to focus on the 3500
data collection
version 4.0.1 software and the seek
studio data collection
version 1.2.1 software
so jumping in i'm going to start talking
about a new pull-up reduction algorithm
that is included in both of the software
versions that i just mentioned so i'll
give a little bit of theory
about the algorithms and they're
slightly different between the two
software platforms and then i'm going to
run through an str kit comparison
where we took different str kits
both from thermo fisher and other
companies ran
a similar data set and looked at
the benefits of pull-up reduction with
the a b
chemistry on both software platforms
so to start a quick overview of pull up
just so that everybody is on the same
page
um we generally expect to see pull up
that is around one to three percent of
the parent peaks
and we see pull up in one instance
because
calibration the cat matrix sector
calibration isn't accurately applied
uh to the data we know with off-scale
data
this ability to accurately apply the
calibration
can be even more discrepant and you may
see higher pull-up peaks and off-scale
data
outside of the one to three percent
range
typically the pull-up that we see can be
broken up into two different categories
the first is
called spectral pull up and the reason
you see spectral pull up is because the
calibration
die data that you run when you do a
spectral calibration
doesn't perfectly match up to the sample
die data
and the reason for that is when you're
doing a spectral calibration a manual
calibration
you're using pure dyes and a matrix is
generated and those values are applied
to your data to deconvolute dye overlap
but in your sample the dyes are attached
to dna fragments
and that could affect the spectra
slightly so you're not applying a
correction
that is exactly apples to apples
the difference between the matrix you
see with pure dyes and what's actually
happening in your sample leads to
spectral pull-up
this type of pull-up in the analyze data
is centered under
apparent peak and you can also visualize
it that way in the raw data
the second type of pull-up is instrument
specific pull-up
and this all has to do with the way the
fluorescent molecules
are moving in the capillary and
specifically across the detection cell
so when the molecules enter the
detection window
center within the window and exit the
window
it causes the spectrum on the ccd to
shift and you can see instrument
specific pull up
in the analyzed data this type of
pull-up could be slightly shifted from
the center of the parent peak and in the
raw data
it takes on a sinusoidal shape if you
have both type of pull-ups occurring in
the same dye channel at the same time
they can be additive so you could see an
increased percentage
at that location of the pull-up peak
so when we came out with data collection
version
4 we discussed the introduction of a new
pull-up reduction algorithm
so with the introduction of the 3500 hid
data collection version 4.0.1
we introduced a pull-up reduction
algorithm and this pull-up reduction
algorithm is going to utilize
sample specific spectral data for a b
die sets
g5 j6 and j6t to generate a matrix
that's more appropriate to the sample
that's been injected
if for some reason you have a sample
with limited data like a low level
sample where there may only be a couple
peaks
the algorithm is going to say hold on a
minute there's not enough sample
specific
spectral information here let me revert
back to the manual calibration and apply
that to the data
so you're going to get a level of
pull-up reduction
either way it's just whether it's the
traditional
pure die calibration or if it's the
added benefit of the pull-up reduction
algorithm
using that data from the sample itself
all pull-up reduction is taking place
prior to the creation of the hid files
so when you view the raw data in idx
the pull-up reduction will already be
applied
in the seek studio hid data collection
version 1.2 there's actually two levels
of pull-up reduction
the first level which is called auto
spectral or auto calibration is similar
to that of data collection 4.0.1
on the 3500 sample specific data is
being used
rather than data from a manual
calibration if there's enough quality
data available in the sample injection
what's different is this is for any die
set so whether you're using an a b
chemistry or another chemistry you will
get this first level of pull-up
reduction
also what's different is if there is a
sample with limited
sample specific data again we'll go back
to that example a low level sample with
just one to two peaks being called
rather than going back to the manual
calibration
first if there was has a
good auto calibration or a good sample
specific calibration
in that capillary with that die set that
auto calibration will be used
if there hasn't been then you will go
back to the manual calibration
the second level on the seek studio to
help reduce pull up is called marker to
marker correction and this level 2
is only for a b die sets again g5 j6 j6t
this is an optimized correction factor
for each marker in the kits
you select your kit during plate setup
and
this is what enables this marker to
marker correction level of pull-up
reduction
on the seek studio it's similar all
pull-up production is taking place
prior to the creation of the fsa files
so your raw data in idx will have the
pull-up reduction applied
so let's jump into the kick comparison
um a little bit
uh on the general conditions of this
study
we did all of our applications on the
applied biosystems proflex system
and all analysis in gene mapper idx 1.6
we utilized minimum thresholds which i'm
going to talk about a little bit more on
the next slide
for all kits that were kit and
instrument specific
as far as the recommend parameters that
we used for amplification
and injection also default dna input
we used the different manufacturers
recommendations
so you can see there were five kits
tested two from applied biosystems
global filer iqc and and ngm detect
two from promega promega fusion 6c
and promega powerplex esi 17 fast
and a kit from kyogen the investigator
24 plex qs
you can see there's two different cycle
numbers either 29 or 30
and different dna inputs either one
nanogram or five nanogram
samples that we used we wanted to use
non-probative samples that's what the np
stands for on this slide samples that
may be seen by a crime lab
so we had a swap from a cell phone a
cigarette butt swab from a baseball hat
and blood on cotton
we also utilized a kit positive control
we did this kit comparison on one thirty
five hundred xl
and two seek studio instruments
so a little bit about the minimum
threshold and how we establish those uh
what we do is we take
at least seven ntcs from each kit and
analyze it in idx at one rfu
we remove clear artifacts like spikes
and pull up from the size
standard dye artifacts things like that
everything else that's left behind we
take
we look at the average peak height and
we add 10 standard deviations
this is called our limit of
quantification where you expect nearly
all the noise to be below
we round that loq to the nearest five
and get a minimum threshold
we did this like i said per kit on the
different instruments
and per die channel so for the 3 500
data across the different kits and die
channels we saw a range of 35 to 85 rfu
on the seek studio the range is a little
bigger but we did have two instruments
so just keep that in mind
we saw a range of 25 to 140 rfu
and this way when we were talking about
pull-up artifacts we made sure
that we were using thresholds that were
appropriate for the kit and instrument
being tested
i just want to go over a little bit of
terminology that i use on the
in the results section before we get
into that um
i talk about traditional pull-up and
this is pull-up
where it's very easy to calculate a
pull-up percentage so where
a single either spectral or instrument
specific pull-up peak falls
clearly below apparent peak i'm also
going to talk about more complex
spectral artifacts and sometimes we see
this
as some people may call it pull down
or a bridging effect in the data and you
can see that on the figure in the bottom
it's harder to calculate a percentage
and identify
sometimes which parent peak the pull-up
is originating from
so for these type of artifacts the
complex artifacts we
counted um the pull-up peaks if they
were called an idx but did not calculate
a percentage
and that should make sense as we start
looking at results
so looking at the 3500 results again
this was one 3 500
xl instrument with four non-probative
samples and one positive control
on the 3500 and data collection 4.0.1
just a reminder a b kits will have
pull-up reduction enabled
non-a b kits will have pull-up reduction
disabled
you can see that um this table is broken
up into
a left side and a right side on the left
side we're talking about those
traditional pull-up peaks where we could
calculate a percentage
and on the far right column the complex
pull-up
peaks which is just an account no
percentage calculated
so it's a few things to pull out from
the table i also have a
chart of this to see easier on the next
slide but you can see that the average
pull up across all five kits was below
three percent
in the non-av kits there was some pull
up
above 3 percent and even a couple of
peaks
in two of the kits above 5 pull up peaks
you can also if you see the total number
of peaks and the total number of complex
peaks the pull-up is greatly reduced for
the applied biosystems kits
so just looking at it in a different
view
if you look at the chart what you see
for the different colors is spelled out
in the legend uh the color red indicates
a complex pull up the lightest blue is
pull up greater than five percent
uh the next color darker blue is pull up
less than five percent
and the purple is pull up that's below
three percent so you can see
that visually um here the number in the
gray boxes is the total number of
pull-up peaks traditional pull-up
and complex so
the overall conclusion here is that the
other kids the other kits
meaning the promega kits and the kyogen
kit
have at least three times the number of
pull-up related artifacts
compared to global filer iqc and ngm
detect so you can see the significant
decrease that the pull-up reduction
algorithm has to offer to consider this
if you were an analyst you may say okay
but what does that mean
to me we put together some numbers
around time
savings so estimating it takes about 30
seconds per pull-up edit
by the time you identify a p an artifact
go into the raw data maybe have to do a
calculation
on percentage and make the edit if we
consider
that the applied biosystems kits had 70
pull-up peaks in five samples which is
similar to what we saw in this data set
that would mean that the non-applied
biosystems kit would have three times
that or 210 pull-up peaks in those same
five samples
so just for editing pull up this would
be a difference
of taking either 35 minutes versus an
hour and 45 minutes
and if we consider then that this review
time for review
we can double those numbers so an hour
and ten minutes to just edit pull up in
five samples for an a b
kit versus three hours and 30 minutes
for the other kids
so looking at the same um for
non-probative samples and positive
control run on the seek studio
instruments so again there were two seek
studio instruments
um we have the results here as a
reminder av
kits have both auto spectral and marker
to marker correction enabled
the non-av kits have auto spectral
enabled
again you can see that the total number
of pull-up peaks is greatly reduced for
the applied biosystems kits and again
the average percent of pull-up for that
traditional pull-up is less than three
percent of the parent peak
across all the kits you can also see
that
for the non-ab kits we're again seeing
pull up outside of that one to three
percent range
and even in some cases above five
percent
to have a different visual look at this
you can see here a very similar chart to
what we saw before with the different
colors representing either the percent
pull-up
or if it was a complex pull-up peak
in this case there is our kind of two
conclusions drawn
for global file or iqc the other kits
had at least
13 times the amount of pull-up artifacts
compared to ngm detect about four times
the amount of pull-up artifacts
so when we look at this for time savings
we i broke it down into two different
analyses here because i wanted to
capture the difference between global
file or iqc and ngm detect
so again considering 30 seconds per
pull-up edit
if global filer iqc had three pull-up
peaks and five samples
the other kits would have 13 times that
or 39 pull-up peaks in those samples
and with time for considering time for
review
we're talking about three minutes first
39 minutes to edit pull up in those five
samples
and review that those edits for ngm
detect
if we say that there were ten pull-up
peaks in five samples
and the other kits had four times that
or 40 pull-up peaks and five samples
we're talking about a 10 minute
analysis and review time versus a 40
minute analysis and review time
so overall the conclusions that were
drawn here
was that the 3500 data collection
version 4.0.1
and the seek studio data collection
version 1.2.1
can streamline data analysis especially
when used in conjunction with abstr
kits so we saw anywhere from a 3 to 13
times
less edits made for the ab kits
so that is where i will conclude the
presentation
thank you very much for your time and
your attention
thank you to all of our speakers we have
stephanie dave and jamie here standing
by
ready to take some questions from the
audience so as a reminder you can submit
your questions using the q
a box on your left
okay so it looks like the first question
is for stephanie
um stephanie what kind of data cleanup
is required
for a sample dna degradation
yes so um for the cleanup of the data
basically you're going to have to go and
open up the raw data files
inside of gene marker um that would be
standard as far as data review from
any analyst in a standard lab and you'll
go through and resolve the flags or
uncertain allele calls within the system
as jamie talked about a lot of those
might be you know pull up artifacts that
you might need to
clean up or more commonly you will have
like heterozygous imbalances
or inconclusive homozygous calls that
just need to either be confirmed uh
or ignored for the purposes of the
comparison
that you're actually gonna do
great thank you um the next question is
for dave
dave how did the new task based training
contribute to your productivity increase
yeah the new task-based training for us
meant that we could take analysts
who um would ordinarily have had to take
several
months um if not longer to get into the
workflow and make a real contribution
and a difference
to our productivity and it let us focus
on the areas that we had real
bottlenecks in real needs
in and maybe even new technology
introduced in and we wanted to put
people straight into those areas
so that we could relief our bottlenecks
there and so for a couple of reasons
that made a huge impact
one and certainly new analysts who are
coming into the process
are useful more quickly than they would
have ordinarily been
and that's encouraging on the individual
level that also made a big difference
at the wide end productivity level too
and secondly it allowed us to implement
more of what we wanted to do more
quickly than waiting
on everyone being trained through the
entire process
interesting thank you um stephanie this
is a kind of a two-part question
did you have to perform special
protocols offline before processing the
samples
and how did the non-bone sample perform
with the rapid hit id did you have to do
any special pre-processing steps
um what did the results look like
okay so as far as the processing before
sampling so
at the autopsy level essentially what we
had them do was
target the best portion and most of the
time that was the deepest portion of the
tissue or the bone
to get the most clean sample if the
sample that was acquired
was a relatively viable tissue as well
as
you know slightly hydrated and
especially if you can see any red or
blood in in the sample
you can just go ahead and directly apply
that sample
then if it's either like in this case
where we had the burnt samples or really
dried out or anything like that
doing that pre-wash that i discussed in
the presentation so it was just
adding about uh 500 microliters to an
eppendorf tube
doing a quick wash hand canting that and
going ahead and loading it after that
that helped to both clean the sample
and rehydrate the sample so it could be
a little bit more available for the
processing
and then as similar with the the brain
tissue that we saw
if it was really dirty it was just a
matter of really targeting the cleanest
sample that we could find
um to go on to the next one the non-bone
samples performance
uh it worked really well i think the the
highest
variability that we saw was um
especially those highly degraded muscles
but for the most part again we had 28
different samples that were
really wide ranging on the degradation
level that we had
and all of them gave at least enough
allele calls to be able to
go ahead and make that comparison with
our n of seven individuals to choose
from
um and i think i already covered the
rest of that other question
okay great thank you um jamie question
for you do most labs see both pure dye
and instrument specific pull up
yeah so i think when you're talking
about pure dye that would be our
traditional spectral pull-up that you
see and then the instrument specific
as i talked about all depends on the
movement of the fluorescent molecules
across the detection window and how the
data is captured on the ccd
on the 3500 absolutely if you
view your raw data and you start looking
at pull up closer in your raw data
you're definitely going to see both
effects you'll see the
traditional pull-up peaks that center
under the parent peak
and then you'll see the sinusoidal shape
of the um
instrument specific pull-up types on the
seek studio it's a bit different the
optics are different and so you don't
see the same
instrument specific pull-up so on the
seek studio the
pull-up that you're seeing is the
traditional spectral pull up that we're
used to
great thank you um dave question for you
have you had any problems with having
multiple scientists on a single case
with prosecutors or defense wanting to
have
everyone who has touched the case
testify
great question and of course it makes
attorneys very nervous
to see that lots of hands have been all
over a case
but the reality is that sure anybody can
be called to testify
if your name is on a case packet in any
way shape or form and that's just the
system we work in and i fully appreciate
and understand that
but um really the person who's writing
their opinions and the reports of those
who are generally called to testify to
what the results
mean and and what matters at the end of
that process
and so i think what happens generally is
that
yeah the very start of initiating
process like this where you got multiple
analysts really in a
technical sense through the lab touching
a case
maybe in a batch processing system that
one or two attorneys might
call on all of the analysts in the case
to come testify
or at least be available but that soon
gets old especially when
somebody in the middle of the process
wrote on tubes or
loaded the pump plate and what does it
really mean well it might mean something
if there's something to find
but generally it it means that you just
put a plate on an instrument or
that you uh that you set up an
extraction but
the real important part for the court
purposes
is to render that opinion after you've
made your interpretation on the
downstream results and so that's what
we're
seeing in general great thank you
does anyone else want to add to that
luckily so um we have a similar system
with our outsourcing lab so not internal
but when we send samples out
and for them they've actually done some
different remote testimonies for
chain of custody purposes for the larger
workflows and then had
just uh as dave was talking about the
primary analyst that's signing the
conclusions be the one that actually
does the testimony so
you know we've seen kind of similar to
where dave has um
and you know you do might have those
people needing to be available
but there might be some you know lower
level needs that we they can do i think
ours was
done with the chain of custody hearing
beforehand
and stephanie um the question what is
the size of your agency
so we're approximately a 140 uh sworn
officers so we're not
one of the the giant big ones we're
similar to ben salem
if you guys listen to the panel
discussion um so not one of the big
giant
departments but also not super small
okay
um jamie question for you if you weren't
using marketer marker on seek studio
would you um would pull up look like
with what would pull up look like with
just auto spectrum
okay so yep marker to marker correction
is the second level of pull-up reduction
on the seek studio and it's specific
for applied biosystems uh chemistry only
so in the presentation i gave the data
you saw
for the promega and kyogen kits that is
with auto spectral only but no marker to
marker
so for the kits and samples we tested um
it was a 13 percent reduction
in pull up compared to the global filer
global filer iqc
to the kits that just had auto spectral
and when comparing to ngm detect there
was
four times reduction for the ngm detect
kit using marker to marker
compared to the other kits so a definite
improvement with the benefit of marker
to marker correction
yeah okay thank you um so dave
how do you have a goal for average
turnaround time for violent crime
processing
yeah our goal is to get it done as
quickly as possible and that
is is really important to us but we have
a mandate
for in our state for sexual assault
turnaround times like most states do now
and we want to far exceed that
when i say exceed i mean come underneath
it
so our goal for those are 120 days
um but we want to quarter beside the
turnaround time of that expectation and
include all of our case requests in that
time frame so we're
really hoping and driving towards a
month to six weeks for everything that
comes in our lab
um there was an additional question and
how difficult was it for you to upgrade
um chemistry equipment and software all
at the same time
boy how long do you have um it's uh yeah
fighting off a large part of that
um is really difficult to be honest it's
difficult on everybody involved
just the logistics of it um partnering
with
folks at thermo fisher scientific just
getting that time right as
well making sure that we have the
availability in the lab and then the
you know even just the motivation and
the brain power to be able to
gather all of that information together
and make it sensible
and worthwhile yeah it was a lot it's
probably
doing all of that together was really
pushing that boundary but
i think it was i think it was worthwhile
doing it
rather than doing it in little bits and
pieces over the course of a number of
years
getting it all done and striking all
while the iron's hot i think is
gonna prove to be fruitful in the end
great okay well i think um
we're at about time i would like to
thank all of our presenters today and
thank you to the audience for all of
your questions um all of these
presentations you've heard today will be
available for on-demand boom
until june of 2021 so please be sure to
share them with any colleagues who might
be interested in any of the topics
covered in today's sessions
as a reminder the technical ask the
expert chat room is now open
so head over there to participate in the
discussions
i'm sure you won't want to miss that and
also be sure to visit the applications
exhibits and poster halls
for a wealth of content and to connect
with thermo picture representatives
thank you for attending kids virtual and
we'll see you at hits 2021.
thank you